season over it's like man you you start
to like i think you really start to
think of like what you really just did
so
not just it's not just that 16 games
it's like all right we had preseason
games yeah camp that we just went
through we had otas he was training like
it's a whole like snowball effect of you
know all that physical work that you
just put in and it's like
throughout the season sometimes you
don't realize how hurt you are or how
tired you are you're just going going
going like when the season ends like i
think like the next two three days i was
like knocked out
that's alvin kamara saints running back
when he was with us at the super bowl a
few weeks back talking about the
prospect of an extra regular season game
we had a poll on twitter a week and a
half ago 62 percent of the people who
responded didn't want a 17th game
uh but you know what it doesn't matter
because the league wants it the owners
want it and it's coming the nflpa has
been negotiating with the league for
nearly a year based on a 17 game
schedule and chris over the weekend i
made a few phone calls talked to a few
people and for the first time i got the
impression they're going to get this
done and they're going to go ahead and
they're going to accept a 10-year cba
with 17 games because it's a very basic
pragmatic approach when push comes to
shove in 2021 if there's a lockout if
there's a work stoppage and as it
approaches the moment where the players
lose game checks and the ability to play
in games that's when they'll accept the
best offer that's on the table so just
take the best offer that's on the table
now because the nfl has a has a a
a very high skill level at making sure
that those that they are negotiating
with know that the offer is not going to
get any better than it is right now so
you can take it now or you can take it
later go ahead and take it now parlay it
into new tv deals that may be better now
than they would be a year and a half
from now and i think that that that's
the direction it's moving in whether
anyone wants it or not whether the
players want it or not 17 games is
coming the question
that remains after that is when would
they expand the season to 17 years yeah
right i mean that's where it gets iffy
to me i mean you know one how do you
work that out contract-wise here in the
next year or two you know i've read you
know the article you put out there on
pro football talk and everything about
that that does get dicey i mean let's
say a guy's making 16 million dollars a
year you just play
we play one more game and he just gets a
million dollars more per year how does
that work i don't know
that that to me i mean you're affecting
that 401ks
uh guys futures all of those things
that's where to me you gotta they got to
make sure they compensate and do this
the right way and you know i don't know
i mean i just i don't feel like the
players want to get behind it all the
way i don't but to your point you're
exactly right and that's what's
frustrating because it's a bunch of
billionaires who have billions in the
bank and it's a bunch of young kids who
for the most part are just starting to
make money for the and and haven't
accumulated you know life wealth yet so
they are desperate and they were put
here on earth a lot of times to play
football and this is their chance to
capitalize so yes when it comes down to
it and then there's no guaranteed
contracts to go along with it yeah the
pi the owners have all the power here
and that's where it's screwed up and i
don't think the players want to bend or
do the 17 game season but you're right
at the end of the day when it comes
deadline time the players will probably
buckle
the choice isn't 17 or 16 for the
players the choice is 17 or zero yeah
right right
and that's that's the choice for
everyone and it's who's going to stop
watching the nfl because there's an
extra weekend of action they know that
we're still going to watch and they know
the players are going to agree to it and
and the issue with when the nfl wants to
start it in 2021 but you have contracts
what do you do about these contracts
with players who have committed multiple
years into the future that's why there
are players who want to move it to 2022
or 2023 there are only 70 players right
now who are under contract in 2023 and
they could take care of those guys get
them a premium right but the goal is to
nudge it back and i don't know that 2022
is the compromise point maybe it is but
that's one of the lingering issues here
some of the players wanting to delay it
beyond 2021. i would get it i i get that
i mean you got guaranteed money and
things like that tied up into a deal
that's not a part of the same structure
that's not fair to the player hey one
more game at the end of the season when
you're exhausted and beat up i mean
there's more worth than just one game
check there so this will be interesting
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports